When Hollywood does any kind of movie or TV
show about counterterrorism, about spying,
they tend to have Jack Bauer doing something
dramatic.
They have James Bond doing something dramatic.
They have Carrie Mathison doing something
emotional and dramatic.
You said you had information about an attack.
But it’s, like, one person, in one dangerous
place, doing one powerful thing.
And that’s not the way the world actually
works.
In reality, the US relies on a web of intelligence-sharing
agreements with other countries.
The best known is the Five Eyes agreement
between the US, Canada, the United Kingdom,
New Zealand, and Australia.
But the US also gets intel from countries
that are geographically closer to terrorism
hot spots.
Jordan, Saudi Arabia, the Emirates , Turkey,
Israel,
These countries often have agents undercover
inside groups like ISIS.
They get something valuable, they trust us
with it.
That could be an intercept of a phone call,
drone imagery showing somebody that one country
is looking for.
It could be a plot.
This was the case in 2010, when intelligence
sharing between the US and six other countries
stopped an al-Qaeda plot to bomb two cargo
planes en route to the US.
And what makes it all work, what kind of greases
that relationship, is trust.
They believe that if they tell us a secret,
that it’s safe.
One of the most important of these intelligence-sharing
relationships is the one between the United
States and the Israelis.
So, when the Israelis found out about a specific
threat from ISIS, that they planned to use
laptops to bomb airplanes,
The New York Times reports that the Israelis
shared that information with the US, with
the understanding it would stay secret.
But the Washington Post reports that President
Trump shared that information with the Russian
foreign minister during his visit to the US.
And in doing so, he seriously jeopardized
that relationship with the Israelis.
To understand why, you have to back up a little
bit and look at what Russia is doing in Syria.
President Trump has said Russia is a key ally
in the fight against ISIS there.
Trump: I say it's better to get along with
Russia than not.
And if Russia helps us in the fight against
ISIS, which is a major fight, and Islamic
terrorism all over the world — major fight —that's a good thing.
The problem is that, in Syria, Russia’s
goal is not to fight ISIS.
Russia’s goal is to protect Bashar al-Assad.
Russia fights ISIS only insofar as it sees
ISIS as a threat to Bashar A\al-Assad.
And one of Russia’s main partners in this
objective is Iran,
who the Israelis consider to be their greatest
threat in the region.
The greatest danger that we face
of the hatred for the Jewish people and the
Jewish state, comes from the East.
It comes from Iran.
For months, Israeli spies have expressed this
fear that any intelligence they shared with
the US could end up, via Russia, in the hands
of the Iranians.
And Now those fears have been confirmed.
If they no longer trust the CIA, that means
that the plot that might have otherwise been
stopped or disrupted potentially happens.
Because they don’t trust that if they tell
it to us, that it won’t go to an enemy of
theirs.
And it’s not just Israel.
Now other allies may become wary of sharing
intelligence with the US.
Without trust, these intelligence-sharing
relationships break down.
And without these relationships, it’s harder
for US intelligence officials to do the very
thing Trump says he wants to accomplish: defeat
ISIS and disrupt terror plots.